[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a number 101
customer service
now with more fairfax with more oh yeah
look at that yeah he's right there he's
waiting for his treats
we're going to start with the discord
question this week yes we are yes we are
what is the evolutionary story behind
the autumn colors i've read that the
autumn colors don't seem to don't seem
to simply be a side effect of leaf
senescence if it is an active process
then i would guess it has been selected
by evolution what are the hypotheses for
why the leaves of certain trees change
color and autumn and what is the
evidence supporting or challenging these
hypotheses cheers and happy autumn
everyone
all right this is an awesome question
unfortunately so i had a long-standing
interest in this question and things
during the brief break since the main
live stream we looked a little bit into
what has recently been published on this
and there has been a lot published there
are quite a number of hypotheses some of
which seem like nonsense others seem
interesting
you want to just show the
three papers that we found sure we could
do that zach
so this is the one we were first
thinking of this is hamilton and brown w
hamilton being one of the greats from
2001 published in the royal society
um as a handicap signal basically about
um signaling to would be uh leaf
predators that
uh that you're not the one to eat they
should move on i see i think this is
actually a terrible use of the term
handicap which is surprising coming from
hamilton um but i would say what he's
really saying is honest advertisement
right an honest advertisement of the
presence of anti-insect compounds which
causes those insects to go elsewhere
makes sense both
intra and inter specifically yeah no i i
uh so handicap is confusing because
handicap typically refers to the zahavi
handicapped principle
which is a feature of sexual selection
so while i personally actually have
invoked the idea
of
uh in my dissertation i wrote about
uh
insects
essentially plants borrowing the eyes of
insects to evaluate mates which i still
think is a really cool idea but that's
not what they're getting at here oh yeah
that's the
that's
plants borrowing the eyes of insects yet
mates is about pollinators the insects
are pollinators they're not predators
right um so in any case i think i think
handicap's just the wrong term here uh
and it's it's honest advertisements
they're after
i will say that the key thing actually
i'm heartened to see
there's a more recent review which you
sent me so personally you have it there
so i can show it this is 2009 published
in oikos one of the main one of the
major ecology journals classification of
hypotheses and the evolution of autumn
colors by someone named marco arketti at
oxford
lists a bunch of things
it's just kind of a mess it's abstract
alone i mean not to say that he hasn't
accurately classified what's out there
um i haven't i didn't have time to read
the paper yet but the but the
the mixture of hypotheses seem both
just not alternative to one another and
some of them are just patently absurd on
their face right but what he does do
is he alludes to the very same logic
that undergirds the adaptive test
that people will find in our book and
basically the point is lots of people
have invoked the idea of leaf senescence
um
as the explanation for the coloration
that basically these are just what
happens
dying they're pulling in pigments that
are useful because that's the efficient
thing to do which leaves some arbitrary
color behind now that has been a
nonsense explanation to begin with on
the basis that different continents have
different propensity to have these
displays so for example when you control
ish for phylogeny
well the point is that logic suggests
suggests it should more or less be
universal and for example i believe it
is europe doesn't have uh
autumn colors the way north america and
at least japan and maybe all of asia do
so
but i mean i i i do think you still need
to control philosophy but you know this
story which you told me i haven't vetted
independently but you you have said that
what you just said is true within maples
within acc and so that's
why not control for for phylogeny as
long as we can no i agree if you have
control the sugar maple has you know the
brightest and everything here on the
west coast we've got
big leaf and vine maples a lot of them
and they they go yellow but they never
go know why they don't get a little bit
orange but a little orange but they
don't they don't go full sugar maple yep
no nothing does um but anyway the point
is a and apparently european maples
don't right simple leaf senescence
predicts that it will all look rather
alike because it all suffers the same
degradation which will be uncoordinated
now what this paper points to which i
didn't know is that the color change
actually is indicative of the production
of
anthocyanins
the very fact that something is produced
that results the color change tells you
that this is adaptive in nature because
why would these plants be producing
something in a leaf they're just about
to lose if it didn't have value you said
that's in this that's in this review
yeah
and is that gonna do you remember um and
i can just look up anthocyanins um
uh
de novo and autumn and it looks like
it's across trees like he doesn't
specify yeah so yeah in any case what
that does
do is suggest that we instead of
spinning our wheels this has been known
since 1971 he says so
we've known it's not just a byproduct
since at least since we haven't known we
should have known right right and the
point is that's why this adaptive test
is so necessary is that once you learn
to spot hey actually we are responsible
for explaining this phenomenon on the
basis of adaptation that one maybe not
then you've got a whole different puzzle
rather than you know having a debate
each time about whether or not this is
yeah adaptive so actually zach show my
screen again this is um the same archety
2009 review
um can they still hear us
we do not know
if you can hear us
all right tommy can you hear us
so can you show my screen there we go uh
so this is the same marquetti 2009
review and just the very beginning of
the the introduction has the point that
you just made bret the simple fact that
anthocyanins are produced in over an
autumn however a fact that has been
known at least since the seminal paper
by sanger in 1971
suggests that autumn colors are not
simply a bipartisan that's amazing and
that does once again
makes a person wonder why it is that uh
the senescence hypothesis is still being
taught in so many classrooms right well
because i mean you know this the problem
is this
any place that people want to be sort of
freed from
obligation to explain things in certain
ways they throw up their hands and it
looks like
you know in psychology oh dreams
random firings of the brain really an
expensive phenomena expensive
coordinated phenomenon in which you
mull over difficult situations that you
have encountered or might encounter
that's a random phenomenon no it isn't
uh or stephen pinker
with his dismissal of the idea uh that
music is evolution or is adaptively
meaningful by saying well it's just all
sorts of things that we gravitate to
it's cheesecake right yeah so it's the
i don't i can't figure this one out so
i'm just going to claim that it's not
figure-edible because it's some rando
process and it's all over i mean the
field
you know evolutionary biology has its
problems for sure but the field
that we are closest to which does this
most obviously and clearly did it here
is ecology
um that you know very often we'll just
make these blanket claims about like
well evolution could have done that like
what are you talking about
that you know that's too fast for
evolution and like well that you know
hey that's what phenotypic plasticity is
for that's what you know all of these
kinds of changes um that we have that we
talk about
here are far about and there is no time
scale at which evolution cannot act
right it's amazing though you'll get
like
there is this
failure to recognize how powerful a
force evolution is and this belief in
random processes that far outstrips
their capacity to do anything right like
the idea that our genomes are degrading
fast enough to explain the increase in
the necessity of orthodontics you know
maybe it's maybe it feels sophisticated
maybe it feels like drift like genetic
drift
is like the anti-religious position i'm
smart enough to know there's no sky god
therefore it's all random i i actually
i'm going to be a bit nastier about this
okay okay i thought that was plenty
nasty no you have not begun to dip your
toe into the puddle of nasty because
what is going on here in my opinion yes
is that
there's
religious folks who we dismiss now you
and i don't dismiss them but who we
sciency types love to wag our fingers
out uh and those are the lab coats right
and so
okay
why are we wagging our finger at
religious people because we have an
explanation that's so much more powerful
it's darwinism true it is more powerful
and it's uh mighty interesting but you
know what most people do not have the
chops to do it well and so the idea that
evolution is a bigger landscape than
darwinism and we can default to focusing
on things that actually you don't have
to be good at because there's not much
to say about random processes other than
they exist right so there's this there's
this um gravitation to a a
it's the sophisticated mechanistic
scientific
landscape of evolution without the
difficulty of having to understand
darwinism which is actually difficult
yeah right and anyway
all right i'm done being nasty okay cool
yeah it doesn't suit you but nor did
that particularly seem that nasty all
right have we so just
exhausted i guess
yeah
um did you
to the original question about the
various hypotheses
of of
leaf color i did not have time to
familiarize myself with most of these
most of which
don't seem particularly powerful but i
don't have yeah i
i don't have the sense that there's oh i
don't spot one that's obviously right in
here but i will say the the sort of
hamilton hamilton was a
super genius eccentric who you know he
was sort of famous for having
uh outlandish intuitions which turn out
to
uh be true
and and he was willing to look
ridiculous
he didn't care he was just a exact bold
yeah a bold interesting mind and um like
i mean and
yes very much so
we met him once we knew him just a tiny
bit um
i don't remember the once but santa cruz
met him oh that's what he was at
michigan as well we might have more yeah
once we were more
more sciencey um
but he reminds me his role in
evolutionary biology reminds me a bit of
in a field we know less about carrie
mullis whom you mentioned in the first
um in the first one you know someone who
was just willing to be very
very out there and didn't care about
yeah
about his reputation i had that
characteristic in common they i don't
think they were similar but um
but anyway the point was his intuition
and the paper that you
showed was about the idea that these
plants are signaling to insects in a way
that is unfudgible therefore an honest
advertisement because it would be more
expensive to fake the advertisement than
just to do the work so it's actually the
proof of work more or less um
in nature proof of work being a crypto
idea
um but but nature got there first
nature grand ain't nature lit as the uh
the subreddit declares it but
the
the point is
a plant produces a compound that is
correlated with its defense against
insects
the cheating and producing the color
without producing the compound would be
more expensive therefore you might as
well actually
produce the compound which means that
the
colorfulness is an honest indicator of
how much of the defensive compound there
is therefore an insect upon seeing the
color can take it to be an indication
that that plant would be more expensive
to parasitize in this other plant and so
both within in between species
the aphids in particular are being
driven to other individuals by bright
displays therefore that this really is
about you know about insects evaluating
uh something that they can see visually
i don't know that that's the right
answer but it's at least a coherent kind
of an answer and it's still apparently a
viable hypothesis
so anyway i wish i wish we could give a
better answer but it's going to take
more digging than than we've had time to
do yeah
all right on to the questions asked at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
quote from isaac asimov
science is not
science does not promise absolute truth
nor does it consider that such a thing
necessarily exists
science does not promise that everything
in the universe is amenable to
scientific process
please comment
so this strike i did not know this
asthma quotation yeah this strikes me
assuming it is i don't i don't think
we're being i'm tricked here but
assuming this is an asthma of quotation
this strikes me as three distinct things
three distinct statements
science does not promise absolute truth
science has not considered that such a
thing as necessarily exists and science
does not promise that everything in the
universe is amenable to scientific
process
i would say to the first and third
certainly true
you know science does not tell you that
you 100 will get there um but it does it
does suggest that you're getting to a
better and better model whether or not
you will absolutely get there
uh when you may disagree with that um
does not science does not promise that
everything in the universe is amenable
to scientific process
uh i i think that's i think that's
right
science is not con science does not
consider that such a thing necessarily
exists as absolute truth
i think
i think it assumes so i think it has to
assume so and i'm surprised that asimov
would say that second thing that's the
part of this that strikes me as very
strange i think this is not his best
work yeah if this is in fact him but i
would say i disagree with all three of
these things the first one least of all
yeah i think i think you nailed it you
just didn't use the word asymptote and
the idea is yeah yeah
yeah science does not deliver absolute
truth but it asks them to add some totes
towards it right and we may and we may
be so
in some realms we're so far still um
that amount that using the scientific
process is not anywhere close to saying
and you know we we did science to it and
therefore we know this is true it's like
well we did science to it and we hope
that we're there for closer but we we're
still miles away
right some places we're miles away
sometimes sometimes we're very close to
the asymptote but the basic point is
that's what you should expect is that
the gap between what is and what our
model says is grows ever smaller and at
some point they
hopefully become indistinguishable which
doesn't make them identical right
the second claim was
science does not consider that such a
thing necessarily exists that's the
third one right no it's the second one
okay
um you want to hear the third one yeah
what was good
science does not promise that everything
in the universe is amenable to
scientific process right now i
i just don't even really understand this
i mean
for me i go to
uh
appreciation of art
yeah but no
completely inside of
it's evolutionary but you know amenable
to scientific process i mean maybe we
need to figure out exactly what he means
by amenable to scientific process let's
put it this way
you got patterns in the universe
and they are all in principle
something you could direct
the scientific method at is it worth
directing the scientific method at all
of them no lots of them not and okay so
amenable but some in some cases not the
most interesting or valuable tool no
definitely not but i would just say
it's almost
the slight of hand is
dude it's the universe
right the universe is the set of things
that can be
addressed with the scientific method
there may be things outside of the
universe that we can't address with the
scientific method but they're not in the
universe yeah right the things that are
in the universe are in the universe it's
a tautology yeah um fair enough and then
the middle one the one that i said i
don't agree with it all
science does not consider that such a
thing that is absolute truth necessarily
exists i think it does assume
i think that the fundamental assumption
of science
is that it is all
one story without gaps that we study
different
effective fields as it were we make
progress there are gaps between them
there may be things that are so
difficult we can't sort them but in
principle given infinite time and
infinite interest
we would eventually have a complete
well but no now you're again talking
about amenable scientific process we're
we're on the we're on the last one now
we're talking about basically whether
there's an objective reality or not that
you know he's saying uh that science
doesn't consider that such a thing that
objective reality necessarily exists
right so
of course it does if it doesn't i don't
think it considers it i think it assumes
it right
yeah
this is a poem
i'm tired of hearing folks flow both
your names although i am sure that
they're trying perhaps it would help to
politely point out to them weinstein
rhymes with hying
that's all
uh
they don't rhyme do they
why hi i mean i think it's the stye i
think all three all both of the
syllables that tend to get mispronounced
in our names rhyme with each other and
then they both rhyme with the first
syllable of your last name which no one
mispronounces
yes but you just made me explain poetry
so that never goes well
ah got it all right yeah um yeah sorry
about that
my apologies i apologize i know i think
i already clicked on it but i think that
was the mountain we have so we have two
mechanisms for nailing it every damn
time do it right yeah
hying rhymes of flying that one's once
you hear it you can't unhear it right
um and i am grateful
i have made a trade with benjamin boyce
the voice of reason that was my creation
yes he gave me um
it's weinstein like the bagel brothers
but with a w
which you know
again once you've heard it yeah it's
right it's good solved it's it cut the
gordian knot on that one yeah very good
and incidentally i forgot i forgot to
mention i had a terrific conversation
with benjamin this week it's the first
time i've been on his on his show and
he's just he's a delight he's so
wonderful he is a delight i have not yet
heard your conversation i haven't either
but i loved it you did live it and i saw
him growing about it so it was
apparently pretty great yeah we had a
great time i feel like
um
he's the one person in the wake of the
evergreen blow up at evergreen whom we
came to know
right right and so no no actually that's
not i mean
as no that's not entirely true stacy
brown
well stacy brown we met in the last five
minutes of evergreen for us right but
that's the same thing for benjamin boyce
it was exactly the same moment exactly
like literally we became powers of each
other aware of him
i became aware of him as the result of
his
video from the library in which he
explained the commitment of all people
who made videos at evergreen to shoot
vertically no you didn't you've
forgotten
he was one of the seven he was the front
of the evergreen 17 and he wrote this
letter he he and 16 other students
unknown to us wrote this letter in a
within a few days of may 23rd
that was like they shot in the dark and
it and it was extraordinary it felt like
oh my god there are other students out
there besides the ones who we personally
know who are objecting to this and i
wrote back to him and that began our
relationship
and we met him shortly thereafter
all right i do have this miscategorized
yeah i i have to say i want a do-over
really everything you want to go back
and live that again may 23rd you can do
that on your own
but you know what that sounded like that
sounded like
but if you're going to be an
obstructionist
work on your own
remember that i do i do um yeah benjamin
and i didn't spend any time on that on
that
ridiculous moment in history you didn't
mention the canoe meeting uh no the
canoe meeting went unmentioned it did it
did wow yeah i mean for one thing you
two were both there didn't know each
other yet um but i was not there
right
i i was thinking of yeah
no doubt how the hell am i gonna explain
this to heather
there have been a few moments like that
yep
well
like the sea lions then will am it just
this week
indeed
equally implausible
oh they were very plausible sea lions
have you any stories of people you know
who have climbed their way out of cogdum
to do something awesome signed a
woefully reluctant cog
i think
a huge fraction of the people we know
who
just make terrible cogs
did climb out of cognitive yeah tried
were forced into it at some level i mean
i don't
i'm looking for the iconic example i'm
searching my memory and i i never do a
great job when i first run across a
question like this of coming out it's
like you know what's your favorite um i
don't know i forgot all the examples of
whatever the category was you asked me
about um and similarly you know just
being asked the question here i've
forgotten
i've forgotten all of the people um
and their stories but i think
i guess the stories that i am coming up
with are more like
uh you know my own having just you know
having having worked retail in high
school having worked in college and you
know having done
having seen
what the fallback position is
and having been assured when then you
know the year between college and
graduate school for me while you were um
you were still um getting your degree
and i worked at the grants office at
ucsc which is
not like a cog in a lot of ways and
exactly you know white collar office
work
with a desk that doesn't even have a
view of a window
and within three days of that i was like
must never find myself fated to this
right
so i that's different though this is a
i'm now working some
cog feeling job how do i
how do i get out
and you know
it's going to be different depending on
your circumstances and i feel like i do
have stories and i can't think of any
right now i feel like i have heard
stories
and they are worth sharing and i don't
remember
them at the moment yes i'm thinking of
some stories i just don't know that
we're at liberty to tell them but
because they have too many identifying
features yep potentially but yeah i
think some people who are quite close to
us
have stories that amount to
did the cog thing
found my way out and uh are there any
salient features of finding their way
out that you could share without giving
up
i think it's implicit in the question at
the point that you realize
i can't be a cog i'm not i'm not happy
doing this it's not a long-term strategy
you leap
yeah
you yeah
you maybe start um
i mean it is
at a different in a different domain
it's the choice between
customer service room 101. that was just
the wall of fire it's the wall of fire
versus customer service yeah
how likely would you say it is to get
kovid 19 from a kindergartner a
two-year-old kindergartner and
two-year-old is not the same thing but
okay
um
we have high cases now and this is our
only real exposure vector
i'm not totally sure i get it right if
the answer is
you've got a high case load amongst
tiny people
i don't see any reason to think the
likelihood is low right i would think
actually i've not seen any i've
literally seen no even pretension of
evidence on this question whether or not
the children the little tiny children
are spreading it to to adults i've not
seen any analysis at all yeah but i
would not think there is any reason to
think tiny kids are safer and there's at
least one reason it means safer
vectors yes yeah right um
and there's they're much safer as
patients as as people they're much safer
they themselves are safer and they may
be much more resistant to getting the
disease in fact that's probably pretty
likely the uh
innate but because of those two things i
wonder if they might not vector it less
well but i've
never not seen anything well there's a
difference between
less well and less often
less often could be downstream if they
catch it less often and therefore it's
rare too well but no i'm controlling for
that well but i know but i just i'm
making the point that these are two
different things that sound alike and no
but less less well inherently means if
you have it do you do you transmit it
it's not a population level well you
know they just you just not getting it
from them because they never have it
that's not a question of loss well well
anything is possible i don't think we
know
i don't think we have evidence and i
would certainly treat them as um
if they are infected as likely to
transmit and the worst that can happen
is that's too conservative because they
were less likely to transmit
can the vaccine passports and mandates
be stopped
is it possible for all of us to hold the
line and make it cease for good
thank you
both um
i think so
i think one
very heartening factor
is that a tremendous number of people
who are pro-vaccine
are vocally anti-mandate yeah now i do
think that there is a
mirror image of that position which
needs to exist
and this is
certainly my position
there are circumstances in which a
mandate could be justified
we are remotely there
right it would take an extraordinary
situation it would be a different
disease it would be different vaccines
it would be different public health
authorities it would have to be all
three of those things would have to be
different and up to the challenge not
this disease
not this treatment not these authorities
right in this case but there is a
situation that
perhaps shall remain hypothetical
forever in which
you
are arguing
uh that
a vaccine mandate could be
the right move
right and in fact i would just put it
this way it is a special case of the
social contract and the thing on the
other end of the mandate has to live up
to its side of the contract and in this
case it is in breach of contract across
so many different domains that there's
no freaking way this thing has the right
to mandate this especially over this
disease right especially given what it
is it's mandating
but
just as i am grateful to have people who
are pro-vaccine and vocally anti-mandate
i think we need to recognize the flip
side of that is people who in principle
could
sign up for a mandate under the right
circumstances but do not under but are
not
of the impression that that is in any
way justified here right that's that's a
more much more nuanced set of categories
that one can land in
than pro or ante
um
so yeah i don't know um
that southwest airlines thing from a
week and a half ago or so looked
promising and then it disappeared
well but here's the problem canada's
moving forward on crazy here's the
solution
the mandates are facing
a lot of people who will not accept them
either out of principle or out of
medical concern or both
i don't know what the world looks like
if we un-person
some substantial fraction
of every profession that faces a mandate
this is not a long-term
viable solution and so i do have the
sense
that the
glaringness of the contradictions
is going to be ever clearer and that the
garbage mainstream media
is going to have an ever harder time
obscuring
the fact that you know
we're going to
decimate our military over this are we
so sure that's a good idea
right our police
how can that possibly be a good idea
air traffic controllers pilots
really we're going to do this to all of
these essential you know what did we do
when essential services were the
question at the beginning of the
pandemic
right the point was
in light of the requirements we exempted
them because we had to get the stuff
done now we're going to do the exact
opposite we're going to cannibalize our
society in order because mandates are
more important than society right that's
really what they're telling you right so
um
so i i do think yes
um
i do not underrate at all
the
terrible prospect of having to choose
between your job or worse your career
and a completely unjustified
mandate but i will say i'm heartened by
the number of people who have said
actually um this is an uncrossable line
so yeah i do think i do think it's
winnable and i think um probably we're
closer than we think
wow this is great actually um it is so
rare for you to be more optimistic about
a situation like this than than me oh i
was just kidding
don't say it
sorry now i'm just kidding
no it feels it feels super bleak at the
moment um but you know it's not helped
by the change in seasons and
and the number of places for us locally
um that we're not gonna be allowed to go
because we can't go outside because you
know restaurants won't won't let us in
if um if it's inside and theater and
things like that and it's uh
it's remarkable yeah no it's amazing
that we're here it's amazing
the conversation about intuition reminds
me of neural networks and machine
learning a neural network can find
associations and data that aren't
understood by the trainers
yes
that
so this is actually the hazard
of
the narrow ais that now
police search and feed algorithms
is that we don't necessarily even know
what they're optimized for we don't know
what kinds of feedbacks they are
introduced introducing into our
collective sense making you know the
people who wrote them don't know
um
and they're also moving targets so we
can't even
use science to figure out what our ai is
doing to us because it's not static yep
yep
boy
um
lots of good questions here
i gotta say the first almost two hours
that we spent sort of
took it out of me so here we go batshit
crazy you both use the term but let me
ask the resident bat expert
that's you
is there a mental pathology or disorder
caused by contact with bat [ __ ] where
did this term originate it's a great
question you used to hate it when i said
batshit crazy
i didn't know you thought why are why
are the why are the bats being
being fought oh i felt an obligation to
stand up for the bats exactly yes you
did no
no certainly not well first of all okay
there is a pathology that is at least
indirectly downstream of
bat feces
and it is
covered public health policy
it is we are going crazy this has the re
this is probably downstream of a fecal
swab
from yunnan province
that descended into a lab got tinkered
and here we are losing our god damn yeah
really not blood
i believe this is a fecal swab
okay i was going to accuse you of going
full literally false metaphorically true
but a fecal swab no no okay i'm just all
literal all the time oh yeah sure
no so all right here's the interesting
thing first of all just the optimistic
man you gotta
you gotta be the optimist today okay i
know i'm on today i'm totally on my day
actually no from here on out oh see
you're lying again this is not helpful
um okay
it is possible that batshit crazy is
actually
if you've seen brazil you remember how
uh do you mean like rio and sao paulo no
no no no no no the movie
um which you should you should totally
see brazil as well um i've only spent
some time in manaus you've never been to
brazil right i've never never been in
brazil ah man
we're talking about the movie i've never
been to brazil and yet i have a certain
amount of saudaji for it
exactly
um
so
the movie the movie um gilliam terry
gilliam yeah yeah
uh there is a particular moment in that
movie
in which i believe it's a cockroach
he is smooshed to the ceiling and then
falls into one of the automatic
printers
causing a shift from
is it bubble to tuttle or tuttle to
bubble yeah right yeah so the wrong guy
gets the letter the wrong guy gets the
letter and then is disappeared by the
authoritarian state
but here's my point it is possible that
batshit crazy is actually the result of
some sort of clerical error from cat
[ __ ] crazy because that actually does
exist it doesn't sound as good though
does it
no no no but it's literally true and
metaphorically toxoplasmosis but isn't
right isn't there something that is
trans so not but in caves in particular
so in places where the aerosolized uh
stuff from the guano actually collects
is concentrated histoplasmosis there it
is yeah yeah plasmosis but as far as i
know histoplasmosis doesn't drive you
crazy it's it's a respiratory
respiratory disease
um so this is something i never dealt
with because i wasn't a cave guy
i was a tent making bat guy which meant
i was out in the open air and what's
more often times i could do my work
during the day because i was looking
after the bats and their roost and so
anyway still if you were a cave guy
doing work in the day that wouldn't have
protected you oh yeah okay guys caves
don't have better ventilation in the day
no they really don't um at least not so
far as i've found no yeah but in any
case so toxoplasmosis is
i'm saying did i just that's right
that's cats yeah that's cats
toxoplasmosis turns you crazy from cat
feces causes uh
rodents for example to be too bold and
to be consumed by things like cats
that's part of its life cycle which is
why it affects the
mind of people who catch it is that it's
it's it's
built to modify cognitive processes or
at least that's the story we tell what
is it
what kind of a organism is it remember
toxoplasmosis i don't remember anyway
just trying
histoplasmosis is a fungus and yes
histoplasmosis is
most common
in
poultry farming that's the place that
people encounter
yes
bat biologists who hang out in caves
are also
vulnerable to it
okay
cdc is the first thing that came up
um
first sentence toxoplasmosis is
considered to be a leading cause of
death attributed to foodborne illness in
the united states um
toxoplasma parasite
toxoplasma
biology
uh it's a proto protozoan
that's not that helpful
um
yeah
not a virus not a fungus not a virus not
a fungus see if it thinks it's safe and
effective
it's the cdc it either thinks it's safe
and effective or it'll turn you into
hitler right you know it does want it
there's no there's no middle ground no
there's no middle ground god i used to
rely on them
i used to rely on them before traveling
to figure out which vaccines i needed
and what kind of prophylaxis for bilaria
given what species were where i was
going of malaria
hey okay that question was
i don't even know maybe i already hit
yes to it um
this is a new one
that i haven't read yet but it just came
in and it's a i'll just read it robert
kennedy jr has sued vaccine makers for
use of fake placebos and studies that
try to have the suba group have just as
many sick people as the test group
for any study where this situation has
occurred
what evolutionary consequences to either
of the groups may be expected given that
people are complex systems
i don't really understand the question
obviously if
anybody
has swapped in something that causes
harm this is this is a monkeying with
the baseline problem
if you swap in something in place of a
placebo that causes harm to disguise
harm in the treatment group obviously
harm is the thing to look for whatever
the harm is yeah i don't know that you
know
evolution's all well and good and
obviously it plays a role here because
the critter in question is an evolved
critter but basically the answer is
whatever that thing is yeah we don't
know what it is
um you know maybe maybe
is the fake placebo just the the
the thing you know the treatment the
vaccine um or is it something else um
you know is it all the other is it the
adjuvants for instance that you know
maybe making people sick i don't know
don't know yeah
um
yeah there's there's too
many moving parts here to answer it as
as written
should we consider the naming scheme
mrna vaccine a kind of russell
conjugation
gene therapy is what we're being given
love you guys
oh boy okay good let's let's just do it
here's the problem
i get that there's a technical
justification for calling this gene
therapy right and in fact i've heard
robert malone talk about it in these
terms he would know oh that's
interesting but the problem is i don't
think it actually even if it's
technically right it's a little bit like
calling an enzyme a catalyst
right an enzyme is a catalyst but that
really does not bring it understands it
it does not give you the right
impression okay the reason that this to
me does not amount to what we understand
to be gene therapy
is that
it does not if everything works as we
expect end up inscribed in the genome of
anything right right so right it's
taking
it's happening outside in the cytoplasm
it then functions as if some gene in the
nucleus has transmitted a message to the
ribosome yeah it borrows some of that
machinery but temporarily right is the
design is the intention right so let's
put it this way and i've seen no
evidence that it does become a permanent
part of the genome like nothing i've
seen hints of stuff about how it could
happen but oh i'm not saying that it's
not possible but i've i've seen nothing
to that effect the thing is there's good
reason to think if it does that it's
very very rare
and so let's just say maybe it doesn't
happen at all
it's certainly borrowing some machine
it's very fancy for a vaccine because
you know it's actually getting inside of
cells and getting cells to put something
on their surface which suggests they've
been parasitized by a virus which causes
the immune system to react to those
cells which at the very least and i took
a lot of crap for saying this before but
it's obviously true
cells that are displaying foreign
antigens are assumed by the immune
system to be parasitized and they are
targeted for death right now
could that be worth it sure
right right but how many cells are being
transfected and how many different
tissues those things are not well
controlled here at all and not only is
it very fancy in the way that you just
described but it also in order to get
the mrna not to be
mrnaced
immediately it's also cloaked in lnps
and lipid nanoparticles which is another
kind of fancy and new and oh wait a
minute there are like there are known
serious consequences for that for some
people and basically we don't know what
the consequences are for most people for
the lnps right what's more the little
message that got stuck into those lnps
that gets taken up by the cells that
gets transcribed by the ribosome doesn't
behave the way we intended it to behave
oops right that's just like so many
different oopses here which on the one
hand i don't think it's that many oopses
if we had understood this to be a
promising prototype and okay it went
wrong in these three or four different
ways and then you know so we're gonna
have to fix that before this ever gets
to the public right but instead it was
like hey these are great and
that's what prototypes are for right so
this is a prototype and that's the
problem um but
the question really is is a gene therapy
i don't think gene therapy calls up the
right image that has never felt right to
me i think the idea that these transfect
people
is a fair
term trans fact okay that which is
different than how a regular vaccine
works um
anyway so let's put it that way i don't
think gene therapy even if it's
technically the right term i don't think
it evokes the right things
lab leak seems less worrisome than
knowing this came from nature am i the
only one who thinks this way
also recent diagnosis ankylosing
spondylitis psoriatic arthritis and
crohn's along with heart failure
and p-a-d i don't know what p-a-d is all
caps i'm not vast is there immune
concern
so i don't i don't know how to respond
to the second part of that that's a lot
of diagnoses and um
you read the first part again but the
first one i the first part of the
question i think is
fascinating lab leak seems less
worrisome than than if this came from
nature am i the only one who thinks this
no in fact i've made that argument i
know so it's been a while it's been like
well over a year i'd say
but uh
yeah i mean if this
if this
if this is what we are being told it is
with regard to the amount of carnage it
has wrought
that's an if
but if this disease is what it is in
terms of um having created the kind of
carnage it has wrought
and it just oops
you know jumped from a bat
and we are encroaching ever more into
the territories of wild animals and thus
the frequency with which zoonotic
diseases emerge because they've jumped
from one species to another is going to
increase
that's really bad news
on the other hand
if this is of our own creation
and it's
due to a kind of research that actually
if it had been put to
a vote of anything beyond people with
financial interests in the downstream
effects of the thing and people could
have said yeah actually not that
not gain a function no
then this doesn't this doesn't happen
again well probably doesn't yeah and
that so that's that's the the argument i
made was that
virus has to do two things to make a
jump like this it has to figure out how
to infect people that probably happens
with some
substantial regularity but it also has
to figure out how to move from person to
person and
that
double
problem is an insulation and to have
laboratories turbocharging
viruses basically solving a problem for
them which is giving them the
opportunity to learn that trick
is
a huge danger so yeah i do think
as tragic as it will be if this is a
self-inflicted wound which it seems ever
more likely it is that is by far the
easier problem to solve indeed
at least in theory
thoughts on the latest revelations on
the nih ecohealth and wuhan and a lack
of mainstream coverage
um
yeah
obviously
look fauci was obviously lying
he was obviously lying you can look at
my tweet from the day he said that and i
pointed it out with three different
emojis
it may have been six different emojis it
was um
it was a
pants were on fire noses were growing i
don't remember there was a certain
arrow with a bull's eye
i don't recall but it doesn't matter the
point is look if you've been paying
attention
you know fouchy moment
was lying
and you know the
nih was of course
anything but straightforward yeah and
implicit at least acknowledging this
even their acknowledgement is tortured
completely tortured yeah it's as
tortured as cnn's um
response to
rogan going after sanjay gupta
right have you seen cnn's response oh
boy have i seen cnn's response yeah it's
all of these people who
you know it's it's a thousand different
versions of it depends what the
definition of is is
you know like
but
i feel like clinton was on firm or
ground
with his argument as much as it was
laughable at the time
yeah that cnn is and then nih is agreed
but okay so
yes
how many different times do i mean
here's the real point the riddle is this
what exactly would this guy have to be
involved in which one now nih voucher
okay
what exactly would he have to be
connected to and how closely before we
would be forced to remove
him from being in charge of the public
health response causing the pandemic
being like
one of a couple of people directly in
line with the very research that even
let's let's let's
give them the benefit i'm not even sure
about the doubts but let's say that this
didn't cause the pandemic the dude still
was involved in circumventing a ban on
gain of function research that could
have caused the pandemic that's not
enough to remove him from a position of
authority over the public health
response and still people the media like
can we celebrate halloween dr fauci how
about thanksgiving are you gonna let us
celebrate christmas
this guy this guy this this guy gets to
decide that
yep all right but
i have in the last week
had a little bit of a change of heart
have you yes i have
i have come is it is it what has bred
your remarkable optimism
i think
an error in your perception is entirely
responsible for my beautiful
an error in my perception right
i'm just
what what does that mean
it means you're perceiving an optimism
that may not be as optimistic oh okay
i thought that you were telling me that
i was being unduly pessimistic i'm like
oh please tell me yes good get me back
to oh no oh sorry about that no no all
right let's let's leave me as an
optimist okay
um
i told you just for today
no look
i actually don't think i i could use a
day i think i'm a realist and i think i
do believe we can get out of here that
actually what lies ahead could be great
i do think we're going to [ __ ] it up and
not get there
but i don't we don't have to it's true
like we don't have right it's not it's
very late but it's not too late right
so
the moment that
that tune of yours changes
i don't know what i'm gonna do
okay you were set go fishing at that
point but um paddle boarding probably
yeah you know if i pick up some fish
along the way then we can eat
for a day
i feel like you were going somewhere
else you're going somewhere else i was
okay um
going to pick up sturgeon and eat
sturgeon
uh
because we're better armed than turkey
vultures
we can get in there right okay
i'm losing my train of thought i'm sorry
i was going to uh to dangle a little
teaser okay
i have changed my tune
i now believe
anthony fauci
is excellent at his job
yes you do yes i do yes you do you guys
say anything more about that nope not
this week all right yes i actually
i've convinced you haven't i
not just now for those of you who think
we're both losing our minds but uh last
night or the night before over dinner
not losing losed
you've got the producer snorting
[Laughter]
well the dog was snoring earlier while
you were doing a monologue and i thought
that might have been coming through the
likes i think it was
it's very silly here today it has to be
we have to be able to laugh we have to
no it's that's what happens beyond the
wall of fire
we laugh
cool yeah excellent uh how long have we
been at this zachary oh yeah
which one is it 40 or 55 minutes
55 minutes all right um
would you vaccinate five to 11 year old
children
again with these vaccines against this
disease now only if they had been very
naughty
no no all right no look here's the thing
that's an unforgivable joke
yes
but it was a joke yes i know i know but
not
everyone will know but not everyone will
choose to
claim that they know wow okay yeah no
no
not these vaccines with this disease for
that age group yep
no
this is school
you did it
that's it
well fire it is
the school district here in cambridge
mass is mandating that all students get
the facts as they come available the
rationale seems to be the children or
vectors of the virus and this will stop
community transmission
look even if that's true
we don't know that it's true but even if
that's true
it is not acceptable
to expose children to medical
harm
in order to protect old and infirm
people it just isn't and the way if
that's our society we get a vote
we never had the conversation and the
fact is look you can make an argument
this is not me making the argument but
you could make an argument hey
everybody's got two kidneys
right some people need a kidney
can we appropriate kidneys from your
child
to save some old and infirm person who
needs a kid we're going to save a life
here and your kid will probably live
their whole life on the one kidney and
be fine can we do that real good chance
the answer is no it's immoral you don't
do that you protect children first and
the fact is
we are in the position of just sort of
presuming our way into harming kids to
protect old and infirm people it's not
something a reasonable civilization
would do and i can't believe that we are
not having the conversation that this is
just simply out of the question even if
they are transmitting it
yeah
it's not only unnecessary
but it's immoral it's just immoral
it is
[Music]
it is um
two more questions
oh one of them is just a comment the
youtube channel primer has some great
animations of evolutionary concepts
thought you'd enjoy it
i'll try to
save it here although it's hard with
this system have you ever heard of it
you know okay
um
wondering what your thoughts are on the
new engenic vaccine from australia
nanocell delivery system seems amazing
it's got a targeted delivery technique
i don't know anything about it and i
don't actually the word engenic is new
to me i don't know anything about this i
don't know anything about this either
but i would say you know the obvious
questions are
is it spike protein based
it uh so in any way maybe it's implied
in this term but i would love to know
does it contain
the recipe for more than one antigen
does it involve invading cells and
exposing them to cytotoxic t cells which
imagine the cells that are making it to
be
infected
what's the basis so anyway we should
look into it but i don't know yeah
okay one more question a guy who says
who whose moniker is irish guy
says why do they put toxic mercury in
our mouths and fluoride in our water
okay i got it
good they put mercury in our mouths and
floor it in our water
because they're not very smart why are
they not very smart because somebody put
mercury in their mouths and fluoride in
their water
there it is
this has been a unusually uplifting
episode of dark horse podcast q a we'll
be back next week with more talk of sea
lions yes
absolutely maybe salmon
sure maybe salmon uh maybe some more i
don't even know what i'm sure they'll be
more coveted because we're not getting
out of this anytime soon but let's hope
let's hope that brett's optimistic mood
both persists and is called for and is
an appropriate representation of what is
to come
let's hope it's contagious
the mood should not be contagious if it
is the wrong mood to be in no this is my
optimistic mood
i know but i don't want the mood to be
contagious if it's not an accurate
representation of how you should be
feeling i only want it to be contagious
if it's accurate i want it to be
contagious if it's useful
[Music]
ah
if it if it's a catalyst
okay
good let's do it let's do it a catalyst
or a rancher of any kind a rancher
catalyst
rancher
yeah you did
didn't really work but i thought it
might going forward i thought it was
worth a try sure yeah
all right uh pick up our book pick up
hunter together's guide to the 21st
century and uh and
give us feedback
i'd like to hear it we really want
people to be reading it we're excited
about it and uh
cannot believe the landscape into which
it got delivered after
over a decade of thinking about it and
never having imagined
any of the current moment
uh what else maybe maybe that's
it it's been a long one it's with a long
one all right
be good to the ones you love and
eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you